five years of federal investigation into
Hunter Biden son of the serving
president and with it all the smoke all
the controversy and all the questions
about his behavior and the association
that might involve his father many
questions surrounding Hunter Biden and
his involvement with foreign countries
questions about the extent to which he
may have used his father's influence in
a clandestine way to to seal contracts
with foreign States and may have tried
to rope in his father's influence in a
way that was inappropriate all of that
is set aside in this particular regard
because what this boils down to today is
three charges which have been taken care
of by the district attorney in Delaware
three charges two of which are failure
to pay taxes more than a million dollars
in taxi is Hunter Biden has agreed to
plead guilty to those a third charge of
the possession of a firearm
inappropriately basically he bought a
firearm when he shouldn't have because
he is or was a drug user that has gone
away that's subject to what they call a
pre-trial diversion here essentially
that's part of a a deal there will be
certain conditions attached to Hunter
Biden that particular charge and that
will mean that the charges are dismissed
so essentially he's put his hand up to
two charges two misdemeanor charges of a
failure to pay taxes this Arrangement
will almost certainly mean that he
doesn't have to serve time in jail and
what it does what Democrats will hope it
does is that it removes controversy it
takes care of continuing questions about
Hunter Biden and inappropriate behavior
that may have involved his father
Republican opponents the Donald Trump
Chief among them have long pointed the
finger at the Biden family some calling
them a criminal family with tentacles
stretching worldwide using the Office of
the President of the United States to
make money so they will hope that those
questions and those issues go away
Republicans will almost certainly do
their best to ensure that they do not
that's one legal matter of course today
Sarah Jane another one relates to Donald
Trump we are aware that he faces charges
of mishandling classified documents are
following his presidency faces
obstruction charges well I can tell you
that a date has been set for trial on
that August the 14th the date nailed by
the judge Eileen Cannon it's almost
certain that that date will not hold it
is in the diary but it will almost
certainly be put back beyond that given
the complexities in in this case
surrounding security
lawyers access to the documents in
question and also motions by Trump and
his lawyers to have a number of motions
Chief among them to have the indictment
against him dismissed so August the 14th
put that in your diary but I do I reward
you that will almost be almost certainly
be postponed to a later date